services und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir sind heute im
urlaub wollte eine neue studie mit drei
leuten spielen werden und zwar mit
dimitri slayer von kollege von uns aus
dem urlaub und am besten mit hinter der
kamera über den slow cooker
ich hab mir jetzt position gemacht damit
ich es erklären kann
das ist der tischtennisschläger griff
hinter den stellen wir uns jetzt gleich
und wir werfen auf diese forderung
immer abwechselnd jeder ein buch um die
welt kommt es geht alles um die 5
welcher der tischtennisplatte
diesen löchern sind zwei leckere
substanzen und drei mehr oder weniger
ekel substanzen wie ich daneben
eingekauft hat und dass man
folgendermaßen keiner von uns weiß was
in welcher der investieren wir gerade
noch extra einmal durchgemischt
unbefangen einfach an
wer trifft darf sich ein ausdruck von
frei der einen trinken muss er dafür
aussuchen welchen becher trinken
natürlich ohne dass er weiß was drin ist
wenn es dem baby z
deswegen jetzt mit ansage hat 30 jahre
lang in einem gulag beleben wollen des
ssv zwei jahren wieder nach deutschland
zurückgekehrt aber er hat weit gebracht
auf jeden fall jetzt in diesem youtube
video und demi darf jetzt entscheiden
welcher gedruckt werden soll und von wem
sage zweite von rechts
patrick max jetzt nicht reinschauen kann
man das alles trinken ja noch ein ganzes
stück ja kann man was war es glaube ich
die fenster noch heute bringen dann
bleiben noch zwei gute zwei schlechte
nächster woche jetzt wieder meine
revenge bitkom ist jetzt einfach besser
wären die wieder mal gegeben vielleicht
bringt ja etwas gutes
ja auch was wir nicht dann ist eine
gerade wichtig deswegen und ich sage den
becher ganz links möglichkeiten augen
richtig zu packen
wir haben noch 20
ich muss mich entscheiden wer zu mir
gegeben
es war er okay ich entscheiden wer etwas
dringend wie mir nicht ganz sicher
allerdings hat klar natürlich ein
reingewinn zu wasser hat mich gerecht
sagt du bist dran und welche du wirst
den ganz links nehmen so man über dem
jetzt geht sie wieder an den kragen
optionale auch nicht riechen und 321
was war so niedrig dass ein gut
verstecktes haben wir noch
es war damals dagegen schwung
links diesmal raus ist so weil es
schlimm drei zwei eins runter das war es
das war's sagte ich überlebt also ist
was wird wohl immer wenn ich trinke
gerne nochmal ich würde sie trinke ich
so deswegen tue mich ich mach seiner
comedy slam dunk
paunzhausen veranstaltung auch wichtig
ist und das alles erfahren stark 1,202
doch wer leute das war's für heute
das anspruch danke am markt danke an
dimitris dollis trade order los und bis
zum nächsten und danke f